like i think one of the one of the like
the best examples of this
is cameron caskey because i've
interacted with them and maybe it's
unfair only because i haven't interacted
with other more bad faith actors but he
tweets a whole lot of stuff he's one of
the parkland kids he tweets a whole
bunch of stuff out about getting
vaccinated in vaccine mandates and then
when i
reply in good faith it's all just
garbage nonsense games to him you know
he he tweets garbage nonsense he doesn't
respond so he's he's really interested
in inflaming tensions and and causing
strife and then when you try and like i
i i politely dm'd the guy and been like
hey you know just wanted to flag this
for you and he does he's like i don't
care he's like i'm not gonna engage with
you on this stuff literally don't care
and then starts insulting and screen
grabbing and insulting my followers and
i'm like
i thought this dude was was more
interested in actually accomplishing
something but you can see
i think one of the big problems we have
with with this country right now is
there are young people on the left who
are
100 demoralized 100 right so they grew
up these younger people grew up at a
time with an economic collapse parents
who were probably struggling
that they themselves unable to find work
deciding to go to college now have
massive debt once again we get into
another crisis and they're like
why should i care about the world let it
burn for all i care and that's what they
do they go on twitter they start twitter
fights and they don't care about
solutions they just want pain they want
it to burn and the three of us have
acknowledged that we like to troll or
that like i was a big internet troll
from like 2009 to 2016 and i realized
how much damage i was doing seemed
subtle i was getting a good laugh out of
it but i think it was really
messing people up yeah i mean that
that's certainly
uh
there's there's something
fun about trolling because you need
irony right fundamentalism lacks irony
and that's their problem like the the
idea that you can uh
the the forboden thing like comedy and
the arts are important
but i'm not a peg i'm not talking about
trolling you know look being sarcastic
silly and and and posting on twitter in
ways that are trying to make a point oh
no this kid you're talking about is just
a knucklehead he doesn't he's only 100
000 he's only trying to make a point he
doesn't care about the cause he's not
trying to make a point no no no he's not
the point is he's not trying to make a
point he's trying to start make a scene
right yeah right so the way i see it is
i mean i i i guess i can understand it
to a certain extent
you know they they grew up in a world
that was on fire and the system is is
corrupt and broken and so they're just
like why should i bother with it it's
like there's nothing to look forward to
when you when you when you're born into
the corrupt the tang system and so all
they do is
yeah i mean what's the what's the quote
from the matrix hope is the quest the
quintessential human emotion both the
source of our greatest strength and
weakness or something like that i mean
certainly
if you imagine mel gibson in the patriot
with his weird haircut and his
tri-corner hat coming over the hill
waving the flag telling people to charge
who is that in american society right
now who isn't just sitting around
bitching and crying about the state of
things who's who's saying you know what
guys we can actually do this like the
only reason any of these politicians
have any power is because we allow that
to happen you're telling me that 535
people plus the president and his staff
and washington are overpowering 350
million people that is physically
impossible but people are unfortunately
that we're a nation of cowards
and absolutely well i don't know if i
don't know if we're a nation of cowards
i think
what i mean i'm i'm not calling everyone
in this country cowards no i i don't
understand i understand what you mean i
think there's a large quantity of
cowards in this country there's a george
bernard shock quote and it's liberty
means responsibility that's why most men
dread it
right and i think it's like when you we
we do it for social reasons too you walk
by someone and they trip a little bit
and you divert your eyes because you
don't want to get involved in that i
don't want to feel
a collective shame because something
just happened or whatever and if you
look at a piece of garbage on the ground
and you look back up and keep walking
the shopping cart test you know the
shopping cart test uh yeah yeah where
you leave it out or who puts it away in
the in the you can you can you can you
can tell like uh i guess i'll be a
little bit more um
grandiose you can tell the strength of
the community by how many shopping carts
are strewn about the uh the shop the
supermarket that's kind of like broken
window theory right i mean i guess in
the inverse of that for those that
aren't familiar it's basically
returning a shopping cart to the corral
takes very little time if any
it doesn't reward you with anything it's
just the right thing to do correct you
can also run and jump on it and ride it
it's fun there you go but you'll notice
you go to some places and their shopping
carts just piled up all over the place
because people go to their cars push it
to the side and say i don't care it'd
take you only 10 seconds to do the right
thing same thing with littering
so i hate that's one of my pet peeves is
when people litter yep that that is the
i i i see i agree with that principle
the shopping cart principle and i agree
with what you're saying right now just
for that reason because i could feel it
like just do the right thing when people
cross in the middle of the street and
don't go to the crosswalk that's 20 feet
away that makes me mad you know what i
mean you do it's we we set it all up for
you to do it right so you're safe so the
driver's safe so everybody's safe and
you because what you felt like it you
just not that like look no scruples it's
it's about it's not about following the
rules it's about personal responsibility
like if we're going to put so much
weight on personal responsibility my
body my choice liberty i want to do what
i want to do then do the right damn
thing but there's there's i think
there's a there is an
we are a country of people who refuse to
accept their responsibility i'll put it
that way
and that's true for the left and the
right you know people have quoted thomas
payne let there be trouble in my day so
that my children will know peace and the
number one thing i hear over and over
again and did for years as to why people
would not stand up against the tyranny
was i don't want to put my kids at risk
right so it's like two years ago when i
said they are coming to your workplace
they're going to come after you they're
going to subject you to this and your
kids they're going to they're doing this
you know the things you're they're going
to do to your kids in the schools you've
got to speak up now before it's too late
and people will be like look i don't
want to lose my job i got to feed my
kids okay well now at the point where
we're seeing all these twitter messages
pop-up people are like i lost my job
because of the mandates right it wasn't
my job you know
my kids i'm trying to pull them out of
school now because of the crt stuff oh
no the board members they're pushing crt
and they're voting against us what do we
do and i'm like
well i would say right now
start speaking up
and just keep in mind that if you would
have spoken up two years ago and all and
got all your friends together and was
active about this it may have never
happened in the first place
yeah i completely agree with that i mean
look
there's we we're we're at the precipice
now i mean it's i don't know if uh
i i hate hyperbole i hate how
then the word nazi gets thrown around a
lot it's very irritating because there's
still people alive who went through that
stuff and i guarantee you they would not
associate what they went through with
anything that's happening right now on
both sides there are survivors accusing
the other side of being the nazis yeah i
mean it's it's
what are we talking about here man i
mean we can't have a reasonable
conversation people have have grown to
the point where they think that their
opinion about facts are themselves the
facts right so we're not even having
we're not even speaking the same
language anymore you say
racist and you mean something that you
you meet somebody that genuinely hates
other people and then somebody else says
uh racist and they mean a power
structure that's been created over the
last four years yeah but that's a good
point we're not even talking about the
same thing no no you know that's that's
a great point we talked about that
years ago that the debate happening was
words didn't mean the same thing right
and that we'd have to agree on common
definitions we're well past that point
oh yeah i don't know if we'll ever be
truly past that no no no no no we're
passing important
racism you know i don't know
ian it is but if you want to ask for
progressive what racism they'll say it's
a confluence between power and racial
prejudice okay so in 2014 with all the
gamergate stuff happening
and then into 2015 as it escalated 2016
we started seeing physical conflict with
trump
i was saying
based off of what tons of other
youtubers had already said i'm like
clearly people aren't speaking the same
language when you're having this debate
the left is arguing racism means
prejudice plus power intersectionality
and the right is argument means
discrimination the basis of race
the point we're at now in 2021 is that i
can sit here and say like i'm pro-choice
and then have someone who's conservative
say i'm pro-life and i'll say okay we
understand what that means let's have a
discussion on the ethics and morality of
how this plays out in in us governance
and what's the right thing to do the
left says we will literally claim words
mean something else just so that we can
claim we won the debate right that's
it's not about not having the same
definitions about them actively changing
words on the fly on purpose
i'm sorry it's about miriam webster
changing the definition of the word
racism changing the definition of the
word anti-vaxx specifically what
changing what the word immunity means
just so that
people can win a political argument they
are actively trying to confuse you so
that you don't understand what they're
arguing well that's they're not arguing
friends that's brave new world right i
mean it's it's that and removing words
well brave new world was was keeping
people locked down by pleasures oh not
brand new world uh uh in 1984 they start
removing words so right instead of good
and bad it's good and not good like
right but it's one where on good or
whatever
you know that's right it's it's a uh uh
what is it a a brave new fahrenheit 1984
for freedom i know that's what we're
looking at yeah but it's what what what
role do you think the fact that there's
absolutely no tolerance at this point
for anybody to be wrong at any point
about anything you know what i mean
you said you didn't like the word nazi
being thrown around right because it's
like you know i think the challenge with
the word nazi is you say nazi and then
say oh well why is it like the nazis say
fascist or communist or whatever and
they tried those were words that were
specific to ideologies in the early
1900s in europe and things like that and
and yes they had prominence in other
places but we need we need new words to
describe what the left is authoritarian
yes but something specific
authoritarian identitarian communist
they're like they're coming nazis you
know they call me nazi fascists it's
it's a little i mean because there's
social programs sprinkled in there but
it's also very identity driven and it's
also very corporate so how do you define
that i mean that's that's
they took all of the all of the tenants
of authoritarianism and kind of combined
them into one and we've it is very i
argue with uh
i was arguing with someone about this it
is it is what the left is today is very
very very close to nazism not the same
thing but what was what was what was
hitler doing he was trying to steal back
land he claimed was rightfully
german oh now you've got the left
arguing we just had a terrorist
convicted for trying to derail trains to
seize the land back for the indigenous
they're identity based okay they're not
the same when it comes to nazis and like
aryan they're very anti-white but
they're still identity based
authoritarian they use fascistic ethos
like there is no truth but power there's
a lot of similarities so
i suppose the issue is they'll always
try and deflect by claiming you're the
nazi when you know i love it you have
the gadsden flag don't tread on me
literally saying
leave me alone and you know i'll leave
you alone don't don't come near me
that's what it meant by the way and they
have the flag of the fists the communist
fist squeezing the snake saying we will
try and i'm like you're the you're the
fashion it's amazing to think that this
because the nazi party is a real
political party i think there's american
nazi party isn't there there's like now
with their oceans
the national association of america the
nsa yeah they were big in the 1930s
obviously you're actually 1920s it was
uh it was big on the east coast yeah so
so these people their hatred for that
has turned them in to that which they oh
how often does that happen no no no it's
pretty common it's written about i think
my opinion on this is that the current
iteration of the establishment left and
many of their
you know more progressive and dsa type
sycophants
is just what happens when you get
behavioral sync and cultural decay
what happens is yeah that makes a lot of
sense it's just part of a system this is
a function of this kind of thing i mean
there's only it's just a fire
there's only one way to turn right i
mean it's you turn to tribalism and it's
like uh the stanton paper the uh the
stages of genocide like how all that
stuff progresses from from uh uh let's
see i actually have it somewhere on here
let me see this probably happened for
tens of thousands so just just to uh go
through some of these quickly
classification is the first one people
divided into them and us i mean come on
man uh uh symbolization when combined
with hatred symbols may be forced upon
uh unwilling members of pariah groups
like the the star the nazis
or like uh maggots and all this stuff or
even
name calling
yeah we're not going to get into that
because i don't want to get you flagged
here but uh discrimination happens which
is you know the the what is it what are
we people already being fired we're
referring to it now as the uh as the uh
the pandemic of the unvaccinated even
though there's no scientific basis for
any of that nonsense right that's it
it's it's kamala harris said in a tweet
recently i think today we must protect
the vaccinated and i'm like but they are
vaccinated right i don't understand what
that means so if if protective
vaccinated from whom they're vaccinated
so they're not talking about protect
them from covid clearly i don't protect
them from i don't know what it means but
i think she did mean covet which is
silly if she did then she doesn't know
you can't assume that but what the heck
that's the issue that you got to watch
out for with con artists con artists use
something called assumptive language
so they can say a thing to make you
believe something
without actually ever having lied but if
you challenge them on it they're like
well i don't know right i mean they
always back pedal when they do people
don't the next one after that is
dehumanization uh like i don't know
deplorable right right that was just
what an incredibly stupid thing to say
actually somebody uh it wasn't rolling
stone maybe it was the daily beast
somebody ran a story a week or two ago
and it said uh hillary's biggest mistake
was calling people deplorables but was
she right or something like that you're
kidding me really you're writing that
right now are you trying to stoke
conflict i mean obviously they are but
yeah asking rhetorically uh the these
things
these dystopian novels were not
uh uh uh uh a guidebook
it was a warning we went through the the
stages multiple times and i think we've
like in some instances we stop at two
there's like ten right ten is like
erasure of the genocide 9 is genocide
right when it comes to the vaccine stuff
it's starting to feel like it's getting
crazy because you have them saying
plague rats
you have them saying like we must
protect the vaccinated it's very like
they're literally classifying they're
literally talking about quarantine and
things like that and so it seems like
that is the dangerous territory but
ultimately what i was saying about what
the modern iteration of the left is
right now i'm calling it fire what i
mean by that is
an ignition started at some point and
there was no one willing to take
responsibility to do anything to stop
the fire put it out so it's been growing
and growing the bigger it grows the
harder it is to put it out eventually
becomes impossible to put out and then
it sweeps over everything it is a
chaotic and destructive force with no
goals the best example one example i
love using is the word whimxen
w-o-m-x-n you ever hear this word no so
there was an organization that said we
must respect all whimxen
and whimxen means the inclusive word for
women
a bunch of feminists and leftists oh i
see it's like latinx but with x with the
next oh my god so they started getting
attacked saying why do you need a
different word for women are you acting
like trans women aren't women and need a
different word to include them
simultaneously the word woman and wmixon
were both the offensive and inoffensive
versions there was not it was not
possible for you to use the right word
right no matter what you use someone
would come after you for violent
attendance because there is no goal
there is no good there is only we will
destroy
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you